well uh hello and welcome to this uh
richard m carp distinguished lecture uh
my name is peter barton i'm the
associate director of the simons
institute for the theory of computing
uh thanks for joining us we established
the richard m cup series to celebrate
the role of
simon's institute founding director dick
carp
in establishing the field of theoretical
computer science
formulating central problems and
contributing amazing results in the
areas of computational complexity and
algorithms
the series features visionary leaders in
tcs
and is geared towards a broad scientific
audience
we're grateful to the many contributors
to the richard m carp fund who've
made this series possible so i'm
delighted to welcome our speaker today
lenka stevarova
lenka is a researcher at cnrs working in
the institute of theoretical physics
in cea uh paris clay
she has a background in physics and is
famous for the application of methods of
statistical physics to problems in
machine learning and signal processing
in inference and optimization link is
the recipient of the cnrs bronze medal
in 2014
the philippe meyer prize in theoretical
physics in 2016
and the irene julio curie prize in 2018.
the talk today is entitled insights on
gradient-based algorithms in
high-dimensional learning
so please join me in welcoming lenka's
devarova
thank you peter and i will share my
screen
so that you see the slides i prefer it
and
i'm really really honored to be giving
this lecture especially given
the influence that you know being part
of one of the programs at simon's
institute four years ago
it had on my career and i enjoyed it so
immensely and
it's amazing what the simuls institute
is doing
so first thing i should do is to correct
my affiliation
so it's only a second seminar i'm giving
and a third week i'm spending at my new
affiliation that is epfl so not anymore
in france but in a neighboring country
switzerland and i will be telling you
about work that i
you know i have recently did a lecture
in this
simon's institute bootcamp for the
program of this semester
where kind of a lot of the works
that seemed like a statistical physics
voodoo
maybe 20 years ago actually have been
established rigorously and
part of the program is about it and it's
pretty and it's
very exciting so for this very special
lecture
i decided to go back to results from
physics
where most of it is not established
vigorously and is waiting for the
mathematical inputs and works
and and that's something that was going
on in the past two years with the list
of collaborators that i give here
the the main among them are the two
students highlighted in
in blue stefano mannelly sarah and
francesca
and stefano is among the panelists so if
you have some
clarification questions or questions you
can he's able to answer them even during
the talk
without interrupting it so please don't
hesitate
so this is the list of six papers from
the past two years on which this talk is
based
and the talk will be about gradient
descent based algorithms or stochastic
gratities and base algorithms
that you know pictorially are the
workhorse of machine learning that is
really everywhere these days so they are
really worth
understanding and studying in in more
detail
in particular in deep learning we have
the empirical observation
that local or even global minima
with bad generalization error actually
do exist
there are many kind of works uh going
towards showing like something like that
empirically one of them that i like
quite a bit
is this this paper by dimitry akioptas
and his collaborators
where he starts by interpolating and
fitting random labels in the neural
network
and then he puts back the real labels
little by little
and he shows that the gradient descent
actually doesn't go that far away from
the
point where it interpolated random
labels and it generalizes pretty bad
much worse than it would if you just
initialize it randomly so that really
tells us something notable about how
this optimization landscape
looks like and we really need to
understand how comes that the
gradient-based algorithms initialize
randomly
are able to avoid the bad minimum
and so the goal here you know it's it's
pretty much clear these days that this
will this cannot happen just by studying
the landscape that it really what
matters is you know even the
initialization so what matters
is the whole trajectory that the
algorithm is taking
so we want to understand the trajectory
and these non-convex high dimensional
problems
and just two points to make to set the
talk you know in practice
the number of samples is limited so i
don't want to be working in some limit
where the number of samples is
is unreasonably large and also constants
do matter so i don't want to be talking
working with with some rates without log
factors and with arbitrary constants
so in order to be able to do something
like that to keep in mind finite sample
complexity and
constants i need to make some
simplification somewhere so for the
purpose of
you know the work that i'm describing in
this talk
this will be on the side of the data so
i will not be assuming any kind of
really generic data set i will be
working with
synthetic models for data for which we
can say something
so the first such model on which will be
the first say 20 minutes of the talk
will be the spiked matrix tensor model
which is the optimization you can think
of
optimizing the loss function that is
written here
it has two parts one so so the variable
over which you are optimizing is the x
that is living on an
n-dimensional sphere and n will be large
that will be the limit we will be
interested in high dimensional
and then the way the loss function
depends on the x
is through the matrix y that is created
from
some ground through x star plus a load
of noise
so x star x star transpose more
precisely
and it also depends on this tensor t
that has order p
and is created by taking an outer
product
p times of the same vector x star and
adding a lot of noise and then the goal
of the
you know interference problem here is to
find back the vector
x star by minimizing the loss function
written over here so why
this model so that also kind of sets
again what
what i'm aiming to to achieve so this
small because it's high dimensional and
on convex
that's kind of what makes a study of
gradient descent non-trivial
it's an interference problem meaning
that what we are interested in
is a correlation with the ground true
signal x star
we are not really interested in the
optimization problem per sec
so this is similar to the machine
learning with neural networks where
we always solve it by optimization but
we are really interested
in the generalization error in something
slightly different than the value of the
loss function
itself and the third and fourth point is
that
this model has interesting computational
properties and the dynamics of the
gradient is unsolvable and this is
something that i will show you to
persuade you of that
so the statistical physics must come
at some point in and this is where it
does so you just rewrite
the same model with the noises of
the with the variances of the two
gaussian noises that i considered
just rescaled a little differently the
way we usually do in physics
and then i take this loss function that
was sum of two squares
and developed the squares and realized
that some terms just don't depend on the
x
over which i'm optimizing and some terms
depend on it in a trivial way if the x
lives on the sphere they're just equal
to some constant
so the only non-trivial term that
matters is
the term here i called h of x
that if i look back in statistical
physics
is exactly the hamiltonian of something
that is called the spherical
mix b spin glass so those in the
audience that know about spin glasses
have seen this smile because that's the
one one of those that is most often
studied in the field of
statistical physics of disordered
systems
and so what we will be so we will be
using that but what we'll
be interested in is at one hand
the you know when i say gradient-based
algorithms
i will be speaking at this in this part
about mainly two one of them will be the
launcher algorithm
with the aim of actually estimating the
ground through
x star in a base optimal way which would
be done
by writing the posterior measure and
computing its marginals
and this corresponds to writing the
boltzmann measure of the corresponding
statistical physics problems and
sampling
sampling it at temperature one and
that's exactly what the longevity
algorithm
aims at and the second estimator i will
be looking at is the kind of more common
one
maximum likelihood estimator that is
computing the minimizer of that loss
function of the or the ground state of
the statistical physics model
and that's what the gradient descent or
flow aims at
so just to get a little bit more
familiar with this model so if you
listened to the bootcamp lecture you
would
you know we told you about set of tools
that you can use to actually describe
what's happening
in a model such as this one from the
point of view of
information theory what is possible
statistically and from the point of view
of approximate message passing algorithm
which ends up to be the best we know for
this type of problem
and this phase diagram summarizes of
what's going on so i will just explain
it and then
in this talk we are interested what the
gradient descent is doing so that will
be the new part
so on the axis here we have the
variances of the noises delta 2 is the
noise added to the matrix
and delta p is the noise added to the
tensor so the bigger the noise the
harder this inference problem will be
and for instance if the delta p was
infinity
that would be effectively as if the
tensor was not there
it's not giving you any information so
in that case you are in the case of
spiked matrix factorization that is
problem widely studied in statistics and
you know it has the bbp
phase transition and that's precisely
what the value lambda 2 equal to 1
corresponds to so that's what
distinguishes the phase where the spike
is impossible to
recover from the easy phase where if you
only had the matrix you recover the
spike simply by spectral methods
looking at the spectrum of the matrix
then
if the matrix was not there that is that
delta 2 would be
infinity 1 over delta 2 would be 0 then
you only have the spiked tensor model
which you know information theoretically
is solvable at at
some point uh highlighted with the red
line here
but even if the noise is smaller than
that it's algorithmically hard and it's
also a problem that have been studied
so in order to make the the kind of
computational question more interesting
i mix them
and if i mix them then you see what's
going on there is this algorithmically
hard phase
appearing that we believe cannot be
entered by any polynomial algorithm
that's a conjecture
and now all i want to be telling you
about how is how
bad and decent and longivan dynamics
fits in this diagram
you know does it do as good as the
approximate message fasting does it do
worse
why so to define
what i mean by you know more precisely
was the longevity algorithm and the
gradient flow
it's simply the derivative so i will be
working with the continuous time version
here because that's the one that i know
how to analyze so it's the
time derivative of the x that's the
variable over which i'm optimizing
is simply equal to minus the gradient of
the hamiltonian or the loss function
plus a term that corresponds to weight
decay or spherical constraint
it would be called in physics plus noise
that either is there and has a
covariance proportional to a constant
that
is called temperature in physics and if
that constant t is equal to 1
then this is the logic algorithm that is
guaranteed at exponentially large times
to sample the boltzmann measure and to
solve the problem
optimally but we will not be looking at
exponentially large times because that's
untractable
our question will be what happens
attractable time so that will be
constant on constant times logarithm of
the dimension or something of that kind
so that
you know we can wait for such a long
time and then if we simply don't
put this additional noise there so this
constant t is zero
then this is the gradient flow
so so going
you know how how that model is solvable
so in statistical physics of disordered
systems this
this works cited here is very well known
it's basically the reference work
that we have in physics to understand
what's going on in materials such as
structural classes
and it so happens that this work
actually looked at a model
very much related to the one we are
studying here
it's it's exactly the same one except
that it didn't have this ground truth
vector x star so it's exactly the same
loss function
but the tensor and the matrix is created
without this ground true planted in
but that's you know that's that's a
complication of the model
that can be worked out and you know this
theory from this paper can be
generalized
and this is what we did i will not be
going into details of the
of the derivation that would be very
lengthy but if you are interested in the
details
actually just um two months ago there
has been a wonderful lecture by
uh my co-author francesco urbani that
you can watch at the
at the leisure's website so this
dynamical mean field theory that
describes in a closed form what the
gradient
flow or the longevity algorithm i have
the two versions here is doing
is a set of equations that close on
three parameters
this function c of two times that is a
correlation function
this function c bar of one time that is
a correlation of where the gradient
flow is at the given time and the ground
true vector
x star and a so called response function
r of again two parameters and in the
limit when the size of the system goes
to infinity
these functions in the algorithm evolve
following this set of
pretty ugly looking equations but the
kind of
important thing here is that we started
with a high dimensional problem the n
corresponds to the dimension was very
large
and the closed equations that we wrote
they are just on scalar variables
these functions corresponding to two
times but the dimension is not there
anymore
so we described the complicated high
dimensional dynamics with the effective
set of equations that are just color
equations
and so since they are you know scalar
they're also simple to solve so we can
plug them in
in a computer program and solve them
and yeah i will be i will be going
through several open problems during the
talk so the first one of them is you
know proof
that the dynamics gradient flow and
launch of the dynamics in this model
indeed follows these equations
and there has been a related work in the
past where
you know this proof has been done but
again for the version where there is not
the spike
so the equations are not are not exactly
the same so this you know this is
something that
is quite probably not so complicated to
to generalize these proofs
including this the spine but
it hasn't been done yet so i will not be
talking about that
instead i will be talking about what
happens if we solve these equations
what insight can we get about the
behavior of this optimization problem
so this is depicted here so as a
function of the iteration
time i am plotting the correlation with
the ground roof
and at the i start randomly so at the
beginning it's zero
and then it is growing event or not but
here it is growing
and depending on the value of the noise
so there's the delta p here so
darker line here is larger delta p so
larger noise is harder
and indeed you are seeing that when it
goes up the value at which it saturates
is
lower for the larger noise so that's
intuitive
should be lower correlation because it's
higher noise so it's a harder problem
but what's not intuitive is that it
actually
for larger noise the correlation the
good correlation with the ground truth
is attained
earlier whereas for smaller values of
the noise it takes
longer to find it so this is
non-intuitive
nevertheless this is what is happening
here that's the property of the launch
of algorithm in this problem
and in the inside i'm just comparing to
the very same lines for the approximate
message passing algorithm which is
another iterative but not gradient based
algorithm
that one that one behaves in the
intuitive way
the easier ones get there earlier but
not for the longevity
so if i collect this information i can
actually extrapolate
the value of the noise at which the time
to get a good correlation would diverge
and if i plots
in the phase diagram i showed before
where this happens
i actually get that the easy regime that
is
easy for the other algorithms say
approximate message passing
has actually part the one that is
colored
uh orange green here that is hard for
the longest of algorithm where the
london algorithm you run it full time
that is
some proportional to the dimension maybe
with some polylog factors and it's still
stuck at completely zero correlation
with the ground truth
and then if you are above this line
where it is really only green
then it reaches the optimal correlation
so you can do exactly the same thing for
the gradient flow
and you will get you know another curve
in this phase circum which is a bit
higher
so the fact that it is higher is
expected because this is a high
dimensional problem with a lot of noise
the maximum likelihood estimator here is
not optimal the optimal one is the one
that samples the posterior
so in a sense by running the gradient
flow we are aiming to solve the wrong
problem so no wonder that we do a bit
worse
so that's not surprising but you know
it's it's a non-trivial curve in this
diagram so can we explain it can we kind
of understand intuitively where it comes
from
so kind of the popular explanation of
why
for some parameters the gradient flow
would be working and why for others it
will not be working
will be kind of this this cartoon with
spurious local minima that either are
there or are not there
since there are no spurious local minima
then the gradient flow has basically no
choice than to good for the good one
then to go for the good one
and if they are spurious local minima
then then
it's a high dimensional problem there
will typically be exponentially many of
them
so the intuition is that it will just
fall into one of the exponentially many
and not the good one
so in this model this is actually
the model is so kind of basic that we
can
we have access to actually counting
exactly
how many minima they are at the given
value of the energy
of the loss and this is done by the
so-called cats rise approach
and so here again i'm not giving the
derivation here just
the resulting formula that is telling us
of you know that the entropy is always
number of something that is
exponentially numerous so is the
logarithm divided
by the size of the system and its number
of what
it's number of the local minima that
have a given correlation
with the ground truth as the parameter m
at the given value of the loss
corresponding to the matrix e2
and corresponding to the tensor e and
again this is a result you know
resulting from a series of works where
these kind of methods were developed
so here what i'm showing you is the
annual entropy that is the expectation
of the
of of the number of those minima but
actually at
zero correlation with the ground truth
this also is the is the quenched
so is also the expectation of the
logarithm
so we actually know when they are and
when they are not spruce locally minima
and if we collect it from this formula
back to my face diagram we are getting
the purple line here
so the purple line means that above it
with high probability the only minima
that is there
is the one that correlates with the
signal and below it
there are exponentially many spruce
local minima not correlating with the
signal
and yet you see that these are not the
same lines
as the one starting from which the
gradient flow is working
so there is a region between the purple
and the green line
where they are exponentially many first
local menu
with no correlation to the signal yet
the gradient flow
happily manages to ignore them and finds
the good one
so how is this possible so to understand
how is this possible in this model we
need to
dig a little bit more into what is
happening with the algorithm
and we actually can look at the at the
following plot
that is showing us how does the loss
function the e
on the y axis change as we iterate as a
function of the
iteration time t and we find out that
either for a high value of the noises
the dynamics is stuck at some value of
the loss
that seems to be you know pretty flat
starting from sometime about
100 to 100 here or it's actually stuck
at that value but then
somehow escapes from it and reaches good
correlation with the signal that is the
dashed line that's
the magnetization and when we actually
investigate whether that value at which
it is stuck corresponds to something
we find that yes that it interestingly
corresponds to the value of the loss
that it would reach if the signal was
not at all there
if the if the x star was not in the in
the mouse so just to the non-planted map
and this is a value of um of energy
that was studied a lot in physics that
has a name that's the threshold
energy and studying the non-planted
system we actually can
compute that value so
so here we make a hypothesis we say okay
let's assume that the dynamics goes to
this threshold energy
and then what matters is whether the
minima that lie at the typical ones that
lie at that energy
not lower one not higher one that one
whether those
are stable or not towards the signal and
that stability
decides whether you get you stay there
or whether you go
to gain some correlation with the signal
and what i'm saying in words here we can
actually put into equations
so here the first equation is where
about are the threshold states and the
second equation
is telling us you know derived both from
the gates rise
approach and directly also from the
dynamic domain field theory but again
the details are not shown here
is the condition for uh the lowest
eigenvalue of the corresponding hessian
of the minima being having an
eigenvector that points towards the
signal
or does not so if i put these two
together
i actually get the third expression here
a conjecture
for where is the line above which the
gradient descent or lounge of our
dynamics depending on what the parameter
t here will work
and so this leads me to the following
conjecture it
you know the contractor is that gradient
flow with random initialization
finds you know in time that is
it finds the optimal correlation with
the signal in time that is
proportional to the to the input size
which is
n to the power p times some polynomial
of log n
finds the optimal solution and if the
noise is bigger than that
then it does not and if i plot
this expression into so so again open
problem prove this conjecture
and if i plot this expression into my
face diagram that is the blue line
you see that that one is perfectly
agreeing with the points that i got
previously by numerically solving this
integral differential
dynamical mean field equation so so this
this seems to be explaining whether or
not
the gradient flow work works and i can
do exactly the same
thing just plug t one instead of zero in
the same expression
and get the same result for the lonzeva
algorithm
that has an interesting point that
actually the line
that corresponds to this uh to this
threshold
it's set to it it reaches the line
lambda two equal one
at uh sorry delta tweak one at delta p
equal to so there is a three critical
point so
if delta p is bigger than two there is
no loss of a hard phase anymore
but maybe let's go back to this popular
explanation what was wrong with that you
know absence or
presence of the spruce local minima at
least in this particular model
the correct explanation based on the
landscape and kind of intuition about
how the
landscape looks like is the following
one it's not the presence or absence of
spurious local minima nor their number
what it really is is the fact that the
dynamics
goes to the highest lying minima that
happens to be the threshold state and
what decides whether it finds the
solution or not
is that these highline states have
a negative direction
in the in the hashem towards the
solution or not
and if they do then the algorithm goes
to the solution
even though there still may be
exponentially many spruce local minima
at lower energy so they're not really
spruce because the gradient flow just
never ever sees them with probability
that is
that is one up to some exponentially
small
factor so
here i should be about a middle of the
talk and i want to conclude about the
spike matrix model
so i showed you you know this is i think
the first time that we have a close form
conjecture for the threshold of what
gradient-based algorithm is able to do
including the constant in a
high-dimensional non-convex
interference problem and the question
would be you know can we apply the same
methodology to something that looks more
like a supervised neural network
simple one we also show that the
gradient flow is worse than the larger
algorithm that itself is expected but
they are both worse than the approximate
message passing there is quite a
considerable gap
so is there some generic kind of a
strategy that we
that we can make them work as well as
the approximate message passing or at
least closer
so that would be question related to the
second point
and question really and the third point
is i showed you that gradient flow
sometimes work even when the spruce
local minima are present
we showed that using the cast race
approach but what about stochastic
gradient descent so far i was only
talking
about gradient no stochastic so let's
say
a year ago i would have stopped here and
say that you don't know the
the green questions would be open but
today actually i do have an answer to
each of them
so i will start with the first one so is
the same
methodology applicable to some simple
neural networks
and in statistical physics when we kind
of set up a model
for a data so that you can keep track of
constants and and not only rates
and finite sample complexity the kind of
popular model in which something like
that
can be done at least in simple neural
networks
is this teacher student setting so now
i'm switching
the mall no more spiked matrix tensormal
in the talk now i'm going towards this
teacher student neural networks
where at the input i put id data
not only iad sample from sample but also
the components of every sampler id
so that's of course you know not real
data do not like look like that but
that's part of the simplifying
assumptions here
then i take a neural network like for
instance the one here
i generate the weights of the neural
network in some again random way
i let this teacher neural network
generate the labels y
using those ground through ways w star
and then i
hide the w stars i never show to the
student network the w
stars i just show to the studio network
as traditionally
the set of samples x and y and i will
have n
samples each sample will live in
dimension p
so before p was the order of the tensor
now p will be the dimension
till the end of the talk and then the
student
may or may not not know the architecture
of the teacher network i will actually
be
telling you about both cases in this
talk and the question is what is the
generalization error
that the gradient descent is reaching
depending on the number of samples that
it got from the teacher
so this is a setting of a neural network
that have been studied in physics for 30
years kind of the most common example
would be this teacher student perceptron
where the nonlinearity that the teacher
is using is just
a sign but with just a sign and no
constraints on the weights w this
becomes a convex optimization problem so
today we are interested in intrinsically
non-convex optimization problems
so in order to make it more interesting
and intrinsically non-convex we will
actually be looking today at the face
retrieval
where the teacher instead of using a
sign
uses an absolute value on the scholar
product of the samples and the ground
true base
or the teacher weights w star so the
labels here will not be
just binary this we will be looking at
this regression problem
the data will be generated as is written
here
the input is gaussian the labels are
obtained as the absolute
value of the of the scalar product and
the neural network then sees the set of
samples and tries to regress
the y or the x on the y
and so what do we know again again
without
yet talking about gradient descent what
do we know about this problem
information theoretically and
in terms of the approximate message
passing that also here
is conjecture to be made the best of the
of the polynomial algorithms so here i
am showing you
the the mean square error of recovering
the w star
which is you know very related to the
generalization error
just like this plot as a function of the
alpha
which is the ratio between the number of
samples and the dimension
and both number of samples and dimension
are large i'm in the high dimensional
limit
and the ratio is some small constant
here you know between
0.3 and 1.2 so information
theoretically the generalization error
can be
zero start as long as soon as you have
more samples than
[Music]
than is the dimension in this problem
that corresponds to the orange line
now algorithmically you need slightly
more samples
than the dimension about 13 percent more
for the approximate message passing to
work and be able to generalize perfectly
in this problem
so now we will be looking at what
gradient d sent us and how it compares
to
to what to do this so gradient descent
on watch loss
which loss functions so corresponding to
the phase retrieval the natural loss
function is
the one i write here that would
correspond to in a sense to
to to neural network with no hidden
variable one hidden variable with
quadratic activation
function so that's an actual you know i
just square the
label sends instead of putting absolute
value i put a square here
and then i'm looking at the the
performance of the gradient flow
so just to you know set up the stage of
what is known
and what kind of we can expect so as i
said if
ignoring gradient descent we know that
starting from one the problem is
solvable information theoretically
and starting from 1.13 by some very
adapted
algorithm to this problem for the
gradient flow
what we know is is this work that that
popped here
that vigorously shows that randomly
initialized gradient descent
will need uh we'll need the dimension
times some polynomial of the log of the
dimension samples
in order to be able to solve the problem
so there is quite a big gap between
1.13 and poly alpha it is 1.13 and alpha
that is some polynomial of logarithm of
the dimension
so as a physicist we always try to look
numerically what's actually going on
so numerically if we are looking what's
the fraction of success of writing this
in terms of solving this problem as the
dimension is growing so here the capital
n is actually what i call the p is the
dimension
so we are seeing that at alpha that is
around six or seven it's already solving
the problem
almost always so so can we understand
that a bit more theoretically not just
running the gradient decent that's of
course nice but that's that's not just
satisfactory so we take lessons
from the spiked two plus piece per mole
that i showed you and we
kind of ask ours okay could it be could
it be happening similarly as there
could it be that the gradient flow first
goes to the threshold states
and then what matters is a kind of
bvp-like transition of the hessian of
these threshold states that drives the
success versus failure and we just test
this numerically
whether it looks like true and it
actually does in the sense that if we
look at the non-planted phase retrieval
that would be the right hand side here
that defines the value of the
loss function that i call the threshold
value
and then if you look at the dynamics of
the gradient flow in the planted version
we see that it's quite possible that
it's again going to the threshold and
then away from it or not or staying
stuck there
so we again hypothesize that this is
actually the mechanism
and put it into equations this time the
equations are slightly more complicated
but we can still do it actually using a
recent random matrix theory results
from works of ulu and square collide
collaborator lee and also the fact that
the threshold states are marginal
meaning that the lowest eigenvalue
corresponding to them
is stuck to zero and this if we combine
it gives us an expression of
what should be the threshold above which
the gradient descent
works as a function of this probability
distribution of the true labels y
and the labels y hat that the gradient
descent is currently estimating
so that probability distribution is
still something
pretty not non-intuitive to capture
but in the within the within the theory
of one-step replica symmetry breaking
that is again one of the methods coming
from statistical physics
we actually can estimate this
probability distribution
between the joint the true label and the
label that is currently estimate
currently estimated by the grading
descent and this is shown in this
picture
i show so in the left hand side i
actually show
the loss the value of the threshold
energy
of the threshold loss as it comes from
simulations
that is the purple line and as it comes
from this one rsp
theory they are not exactly equal here
that's not the conjecture here
is that this is not exact but they are
close so
so we use this as an approximation on
the right hand side i am showing again
numerically obtained moments of the
distribution on which the formula
depends
and the moment is computed from the one
rsp theory and the
agreement is pretty good so when we put
these things together
you know ignoring the little differences
this actually leads us to an
estimation of the gradient decent
threshold that is about
13.8 so if i put it back onto this axis
i showed you that the numerics this
constant starting from which
gradient descent is working looks like 7
from approximated theory we get
something like 13.8
so we are not sure where the discrepancy
comes from whether it is finite size
effects and the numerics would actually
converge to the 13.8
or whether it is the small difference
between the exact result
and the one rsv approximation so both is
both is possible but what is
nevertheless clear
is that it seems that it's a constant
the the polylog of b is not needed
so here is another open problem proof
that
you know any constant times p is
actually a sufficient number of samples
for randomly initialized gradient
descent to solve phase retrieval
in time that is p times times some
polylog p
so in the time the polylog p is not
avoidable
because otherwise you're just stuck at
kind of zero
correlation but in the number of samples
the conjecture
from from our work is that it should be
avoidable and that the true constant is
somewhere around 7 or 13.
but what about the gap between the
the performance of the approximate
message passing
and of the grand descent there is you
know still big difference between
say one and ten so can we somehow close
that gap
can we do something generic that would
diminish that gap
so that's the question for the next a
few slides
and that that corresponds to to this you
know when i was concluding about the
spike matrix model that was the second
input
so that's the second point to which we
are doing and
surprisingly or not we will do that by
over parametrization
so let's still look at the phase
retrieval so the problem the regression
problem we are trying to solve here is
still the same
so phase retrieval with random gaussian
data and the teacher
coming from a gaussian and generating
the labels this didn't change
but what changes now is the loss
function so now the loss function that i
will be considering
doesn't correspond anymore to simple
the simplest neural network with no
hidden unit or one hit unit that's the
same
now the neural network will have m
hidden units and i will be working in a
regime where the number of hidden units
is bigger than the dimension p so this
is the over parametrized two-layer
neural network
i will be optimizing over the weights of
the first layer this matrix w
and the second layer will be fixed the
weights of the second layer will be
fixed to one over m
or to one and i use the scaling one over
m so i'm not really
learning here the second layer but that
would know the conjecture kind of is
that that wouldn't change much in the in
the overall message
of this so
again i'm just running gradient flow on
this loss function with a random
initialization
so how does this behave so this is a
wide over parameterized two-layer neural
network does this solve the phase you
achieve
or not and this is from a paper
that that we that came up
in june with a colleague from uiu eric
vanden eiden and
same student as stefano sarah mannelly
where uh in two theorems we kind of
answered
provide some answer to this question
so the first theorem is it is purely
geometric
it is telling us that if you are looking
at the loss function as i just defined
it
then if alpha is so alpha again was the
ratio between the number of samples and
the dimension
so if alpha is smaller than 2 then this
loss function has many spiritual
minima and if alpha is bigger than two
then the probability that the only local
minima that
is there corresponds to the ground roof
that would be this a star that is just
the
teacher vector times is transposed is
actually the only one
so we believe that this is actually with
probability one but what we could prove
is this is only with positive
probability
but there is something clearly happening
about the threshold alpha equal to
and when we and this is purely geometric
no gradient descent yet
but when we put this together with our
second theorem about the gradient
descent
that tells us that in terms of this
parameter
a that is the weight matrix times its
transpose
the gradient descent always goes to
global minima
then putting these two together actually
if there is only one global minima
corresponding
to the to the ground true with finite
probability well then the gradient
descent also goes there
so this means that the gradient descent
solved this problem by optimizing this
loss function corresponding to the over
parameterized
neural network starting from alpha equal
to
and here is just a little plot that you
know that shows that
just running numerically writing descend
on relatively small systems
is pretty consistent with that result so
if i put that back into onto undo the
axis of alpha
i obtain that by using over
parameterized nail network
i can push down the threshold at re
starting from which the gradient flow is
working down to two
so not yet to the 1.13 of amp but
much lower than if i was not over
parameterizing
so the conclusion is here that over
parameterized neural networks
need fewer samples and this is a
quantification of how much fewer samples
in this particular model
and the open problem would be and that i
i really don't know the answer like is
there a neural network architecture
maybe if you make it deeper or over
parametrized differently
for which the plane randomly slice
guardian descent would just need less
than alpha 2 so less than 2p samples so
i think that's an interesting
kind of concrete question for this
particular model
and i i might have time for the third
point
stop me if i don't but i wanted to
mention
the third point about what can we say
about the stochastic gradient descent so
far i was only talking about gradients
and or more precisely gradient flow
because i was always considering the
continuous time
version because that's the one that is
easier to analyze
so what about stochastic gravities so
first of all a reminder was
what's stochastic it's you know the same
thing but we are taking the samples one
by one
so when we say stochastic writing decent
in the literature we mean usually one of
the two following things
so either we mean the online stochastic
grading descent
where each iteration uses a fresh sample
and never uses a sample that was ever
seen before
and i like to call it online stochastic
running decent
that one is simpler to analyze but it's
also less interesting because it
minimizes directly the population loss
and there is no notion of the
generalization gap
the training test are the same so a lot
of the mysteries about how comes the
train error can be so much smaller than
the test error
that we are kind of asking and deep
learning cannot really be answered by
looking at the online stochastic gravity
scene
it's also not used in practice what's
used in practice is multipass stochastic
gradient descent
where we use one or few samples at the
time but we reuse the samples many times
and this is much harder to analyze this
has much less kind of existing theory
but that's the one we want to look at
because it's used in practice and it can
access
you know non-trivial generalization gap
then so
can we do that so first of all the first
step above which i didn't even talk
before
because it was obvious how bright and
descends in the limit of small learning
rate becomes gradient flow
for the stochastic gradient descent is
not so clear
what is the limit of the infinitely
small learning rate that actually is
well defined
so so i'm just explaining it on this
slide so if i define stochastic gradient
descent using this variable
s of t that would be you know
one for some samples and zero for some
other samples
so if i do what is usually done in
stochastic gradient descent
is that every at every time step i
randomly choose who is in the batch and
who is not in the batch
well then this doesn't have a
well-defined limit of the learning
rate going to zero it doesn't really
have a gradient flow
limit so this is not so nice
for the dynamic community of theory so
we instead define a slightly different
version of stochastic iron descendant we
call persistent stochastic variant
descent
where we as before have some fraction of
samples that are in the batch
but instead of reshuffling the batch at
every time step randomly
we actually decide at each time step
whether we keep
or not the the sample in the batch
and we we keep the we keep that sample
with some typical time that we call here
the persistence time following the rule
that is written here
so if we do it this way then we can take
the limit of the
learning rate to zero and it has
actually a well-defined stochastic guide
in flow limit
so that is the that is the that is the
dynamics that's
that i will be analyzing on a model
that here will be um slightly different
so it's not the phase retrieval or the
model on which we will be analyzing this
it's uh it's just a gaussian mixture a
supervised
learning of a gaussian mixture so in the
two cluster case
that is on the left here i have two
clusters
one cluster is plus labels plus one
cluster is labels
minus and i'm trying to separate them so
that's very simple i can just imagine
there is some hyperplane in the
middle and separating them but the
clusters are really noisy
so i'm in a regime where i will not be
able to separate perfectly
and yet so so this will even lead to a
convex problem so that's more for kind
of a
comparison but the one that will be
interestingly non-convex is the three
cluster case
where i have three gaussian clusters
two on the periphery and one in the
middle but the two on the periphery they
have the same label
so this is a data set that is no longer
linearly separable
so actually to be able to to to to have
some meaningful learning
the loss function that i will be using
for these three clusters
is is actually is actually kind of
you know using the the structure of the
data set and i will be doing logistic
regression
but not directly on the data points but
on the
you know as specified here on this c c
my
mu okay but
whether it is the two cluster case or
the three cluster case
how do we describe the full trajectory
of the granules
the complexity is really not so much
helping us to describe
the the full trajectory so this will be
again done
with the dynamical mean fee theory but
this time with a little bit more
advanced version of it because for the
perceptron uh
case the the the simple one that we used
before is is not
quite working it's not it's not so the
equations do not close
so simply but this period is the same
here
we start with this high dimensional
markovian dynamics of a strongly
correlated system and the dynamic domain
field theory
maps it into non-markovian so
dynamics with memory but of one single
degree of freedom
so this is where we lose the high
dimension and get
a system that we can actually plug into
computer
and analyze and here
uh rd you know is that one dimensional
system but this is a little
you know i want to get to the results or
conclude so i will not be explaining
this in detail but again
i was mentioning this lecture by pierre
francesco obani in lesos
where he actually derives this equation
in details
peter put on his video does that mean i
should be concluding
maybe
sorry you have five minutes
five minutes great that's fine so let me
just like okay this
i will not be explaining every detail
but let me just explain what this
is so here i actually the claim is that
the
dynamics in this of this classifier
in for the data set that is this that is
this high dimensional gaussian mixture
behaves in the same way as the following
scholar stochastic process for this
variable h
of t t is just the iteration time that
and the stochastic process actually has
several types of noise
so it has for instance a noise that
corresponds to the regularization lambda
which is just the ordinary reach
legalization
but it also has a noise that plays
exactly the same role of the rich
regularization
but that came from the dynamics that is
not there explicitly
so this is some kind of implicit rich
regularization that
comes from this variable s of t that was
the variable in the in the stochastic
guiding descent that was deciding which
sample is there and which sample is not
there so that's that's kind of an
interesting you know interpretation of
what this stochastic model
stochastic process actually is this is a
interpretation of
how kind of the implicit regularization
might be coming
out in these type of problems the second
term
is directly the noise coming from the
stochastic grading descent because you
might be saying
that here i have batches that are still
extensively big so maybe
the noise doesn't matter so much so it
actually does it's still
explicitly there even in this effective
dynamics
and then there is a dynamical noise here
that is just gaussian with some
covariance matrix
mc that is consistently computed you
know for
via set of closed equations
and then there is some memory kernel
here mr that also needs to be
consistently computed
from a set of equations so i put these
in very small because you know these are
these are kind of hard to grasp in just
like one minute
but it's again some some work that comes
from
recent works in statistical physics and
that can be directly adapted
to this problem as we did in this paper
here again open problem would be of
course challenge once
once one goes in detail through what
this color stochastic process is can we
actually prove
that it is equivalent to what the grad
what the
stochastic gradient flow is doing in in
this problem
and you know once you compute it
numerically all these uh quantities uh
from these equations then you can
compute everything else
including the training loss the test
laws
the generalization here the
corresponding accuracy is this
is this is highlighted in this set of
equations
so with that what you can do is you can
plot for instance
a picture like that where i plot the
generalization error
and the training error in the intersect
the generalization here in the main part
is a function of the time and now the
points
that's just running the stock the
persistent stochastic gradient descent
numerically on this data set
so this is just a plain simulation of
this simple neural network
and the lines that's a result that i get
from the dynamic community fury
so it is you know you can see that it is
describing the whole trajectory what is
the generalization error at any given
time
for the persistent stochastic guiding
descent so you see that at large times
it is going somewhere
but at intermediate times there would be
some early stopping to do here and
depending on the batch size
and order on the persistence time is not
exactly the same curve
and quite interestingly even the the
orange points actually would be
the normal stochastic gradient descent
and the line corresponding
that is plotted there is is in a sense
not
quite justified by our theory we just
kind of ad hoc discretize the theory in
the same way we would discretize to do
the canonical stochastic
descent it still seems working which is
a bit puzzling to us
it really kind of we don't really know
why should it
but so we didn't maybe even need to do
this this persistent stochastic guidance
descent for this theory to work
or maybe yes maybe there is some small
error that doesn't show up on
you know on this comparison with numeric
so this we don't know yet
and you can you know look at other
things for instance this um
this case of two clusters is quite
interesting because if you don't do the
stochastic gradient descent but
fulbright guiding this and that would be
this
this picture that is of course just a
special case of the equations that i
just wrote
it has this specular behavior that if
you
initialize so r is the variance at
initialization if you initialize at zero
with really small variance
then after one iteration you reach the
base optimal error
and then the gradient descent is
actually driving you away from it
and training accuracy is growing you
know this is a regime where you're
interpolating
the training accuracy goes to one but
the test error is getting worse
so actually after one iteration you were
perfectly optimal
but then the gradient is driving you
away from the perfect generalization
not perfectionist the optimal
generalization point
so that's a kind of specular property of
this particular two cluster model that
we that we
discovered in this paper and
and you can look at other things such as
you know looking
how different the dynamics is when you
are changing the batch size
and comparing how the dynamics changes
when you're changing the ridge
legalization of the loss
and this is what's on these two pictures
so i see that
as i'm changing the batch size the time
scale where i start to decrease
is changing because the number of
iterations i need with smaller batch
size is
bigger so this intuitive but otherwise
if the curves
look kind of comparable to the ones if i
was adding more and more regularization
in the sense that
the blue ones that is just gradient
descent no
real backsides one is as if i was
regularizing
only a little in this case and
regularizing
a lot is actually corresponding to the
smallest batch slice in this in this
picture but
you know that's that's just like
observing how the
how the curves look like so there's no
like formal statement here
so this was the last figure that i
wanted to show you
and just to conclude so you know i was
telling you about this dynamical mean
field theory and the results coming from
it
that is able to track the full
trajectory of the grounding descent or
the stochastic realities and for a range
of
our synthetic models for the data and
there are of course many directions in
which this
this we would want to uh extend it
including all the open problems that i
stated we would like to have more
more math and rigor into that but also
deduce more of insights just by looking
of what the dynamic and
your equations are telling us as a
function of all the hyper parameters and
the nature of the noise that
i was describing in the in the equations
and we can look at other data models
these are not the only ones for which
this this this can be written and we can
look at networks that actually have
hidden variables
and of variants of the gradient
descending stochastic guardian descent
that have momentum for instance
etc so this is hopefully to come
and i just flashed back the list of
papers from the beginning
that that i covered in this store and
open for the discussion
if there is still time for the
discussion
thanks very much lenko that was that was
a fascinating
uh talk we've actually run over time
so um we probably should take
questions offline but um you know thank
you very much that was a
really excellent excellent talk
thank you so can i no i don't see any
questions in the questions so yeah so
please send me questions if you have
some
sorry for running overtime